making his uh triumphant return today
defiant and triumphant i would say uh to
the david pakman show is andrew yang
entrepreneur
turned politician author of the new book
forward notes on the future of our
democracy which i was uh glad glad to
take a look at a couple weeks ago when
you sent it to me um former democratic
presidential primary candidate former
new york city mayoral candidate i mean
there's just so much to talk about but
it's great having you back on thanks
david it's great to be here it's been so
long been far too long it has so you
know you and i we have many things in
common and many things not in common one
of the things we have in common is we we
are pragmatists we both run for
president david is that that's that
would happen i can't i i'm a naturalized
citizen so i cannot do it that is
something i i unless the law changes i
will never be able to do sadly but um
but in our pragmatism
i think we both prioritize solving
problems and that comes through in the
book it came through in your
presidential campaign etc to solve
problems we've got to figure out what
created the problem so to what do you
attribute the current division that
exists politically in the united states
in a word david incentives but one of
the things i found
in researching and writing my book was
that this is not normal we are not in
normal times if you rewind a number of
decades well if you go way back to the
founding of the country uh then they're
not fans of political parties the
republican party comes about in the wake
of the civil war starts out as the
northern anti-slavery party but the two
parties
despite trading power back and forth for
about a hundred years were kind of
indistinguishable ideologically
until the 1960s reorganizes things
somewhat with the civil rights movement
and then you have the end of the
fairness doctrine the beginning of cable
tv in the 90s and so the two parties
have started diverging ideologically and
politically
really over the last 30 40 years or so
and that's given rise to the urban rural
divide the educated less educated divide
but all the political incentives now are
around the extremes because
83 plus of the congressional races are
decided in the primary so in each party
in order to get reelected you just want
to not get primaried which means you're
going to be trying to keep people off
your back in the extreme flank of your
party see this very clearly with the
republicans or if someone says a bad
word about trump they then get attacked
and cast out so you have these political
incentives around the extremes and then
you have media incentives compounding
those extremes by separating us into
ideological armed camps at this point
and then you have social media on top of
it so this is why we feel like we're
careening towards political violence and
worse and i just want to commend folks
like you because i do see independent
media as the antidote like you all
aren't as ideological or
um inflammatory in many cases of course
there are people that are like that but
not you david
so
so the the the polarization we're
feeling is now a very predictable result
of all of the political and media
incentives that are driving the system
okay i i mostly i you know small issues
i could take with that but for our
discussion today basically agree with
with the assessment so we then get to
the forward movement the forward party
bridging this gap finding something that
maybe can cross the traditional party
lines that more people can agree with
um first question is what is it that you
think would be appealing to people from
these two sometimes ideological extremes
sometimes just ideological differences
oh i would say that polarization is a
bad thing for everyone let's say you're
on the left and you'd like to get
something done on climate change and you
look up and you're like why can we not
get anything done on climate change uh a
republican senator said something to me
that really hit home she said
andrew we
get rewarded more for keeping an issue
around than resolving it
uh and the example i've been using is
marco rubio suggesting immigration
reform and then he gets shipped by the
republican party he's like never mind
never mind nothing to see
so if you are
on the left and you're like why can't we
do things that 60 70 75 percent of us
walk uh then you'd want to try and
reform this system to become more
rational and more responsive to the
desire of the majority of us and you can
go down the list on issues you go
immigration and go climate change let's
take climate change i mean so i think
this is where we might have our first
disagreement completely agree with you
that the senate the system by explicitly
and implicitly with things like the term
limits that we have almost always having
to be campaigning for your next election
all these different things
don't prioritize solutions to long-term
problems like climate change i agree
with everything you've said and yet
part of climate change is
a huge portion of one side
doesn't believe it's real or if they do
they don't believe humans are a factor
so this is where i get to your analysis
is great
i don't think it accounts for it's more
than that when one side simply won't
accept the science how do you get those
people to buy in
all right so let's play this out yeah
um what proportion of americans don't
believe that climate change is real or
caused by humans
the last i've seen it's uh oh we i wish
i had the data in front of me i think
it's about
half or 60 percent of republicans don't
believe it's caused by humans and maybe
25 33 something like that don't believe
it's even happening at all yeah so that
lines up with what what i thought the
numbers were roughly um so let's imagine
that you have
like gross numbers 35 percent of
americans who either don't think climate
change is caused by humans or it's not a
big deal or whatever it is and that that
percentage is declining happily or
unhappily because it's becoming so
apparent apparent around us yeah so
right now you have a republican party
that is motivated by that
uh
you know let's call it for argument's
sake um
roughly half of the republican party or
a bit more does not think climate change
is something we should do anything about
sure
the problem is that that relative
minority
ends up controlling the agenda for
half of the country and then can stall
any real move uh to change it yes
so let's say hypothetically instead of
having two parties we had four parties
or five parties and you had progressive
democrats moderate democrats forwardists
moderate republicans uh and conservative
republicans and the conservatives would
be like hey climate change bunk let's
not do a thing but then you you'd have
four
like the four other groups look up and
say
um
we should do something about it so what
you're seeing here is is not quite
minority rule but it's minority
uh
veto or it's minority keeping anything
from happening and so this is the system
as it currently
is made up uh so
the thing that i want people to come to
grips with is that politics right now is
completely tribal
um and you can be very very angry at
what another tribe says or feels but the
problem right now is that we only have
two tribes and it doesn't take much to
gum up the works which is why we're all
losing our minds getting more polarized
and frustrated yeah and so this this
gets us to really a discussion of of
third parties and i'm curious
i have a view as to why third parties
have not become uh
more significant at the national level
i'm curious what what your view is my
view is it's essentially two things it's
not for lack of want of more options
um it's not for a
lack of political diversity it's not
because of the desire for more political
diversity in the major parties people
want that it's two things one
that the the side whose third party does
best ultimately risks being a spoiler
and people who say i'd like a third this
is the age-old green party thing i mean
this is not new right oh i like this it
probably gets the people i really don't
want in power if it goes well and number
two connected to that how politics is is
financed in the united states as well
those are for me the two main reasons
why what do you see
in a word incentives
so so if you uh if you
decide to break from the two major
parties all of a sudden you don't have
uh capital structure you don't have
votes you don't have media and so you're
in the wilderness now i i do want to
return to the you're going to mess it up
for whatever team you're closer to
this is one reason why the first big
move the forward party is making is to
push for ranked choice voting combined
with open primaries because if you had
rank choice voting in an election you
could vote green one democrat two
republican three and then no no one
needs to worry about it um the the
problem right now is that the duopoly
wants to stifle any competition and it
uses fear it's like uh if i had a buck
for every time someone said oh you're
gonna mess it up for the democrats even
though the numbers do not make it clear
that that's exactly what i'd be doing
and i have said absolutely nothing about
uh you know a national race like i'm
trying to get things done at the local
level for for 22. but if you were to
shift to rank choice voting then the
spoiler effect disappears which is
exactly why we need it and also exactly
why the duopoly doesn't want to talk
about it because to your point at this
point a majority of americans want to
move on from the duopoly we know it's
not working but we just keep being told
we can't have it because of this archaic
voting system that we could change if
enough of us got together to say look
let's just do everything by ranked
choice voting no more spoiler effect
but the parties don't want that because
the parties know that we actually don't
like them very much
and that the only reason we're choosing
a is because they're trying to scare us
about b
so the question then becomes how do you
i mean this is sort of like when an
elected official says
uh as soon as i get in i'm gonna do
uh voting you know election reform and
campaign finance performance like hold
on a second you're gonna come to power
under the system we have and then change
the system that worked to get you in
power it to go to incentives it doesn't
seem like you'll be super incentivized
to do that the same question sort of
applies here if we need to make the
changes you're talking about to campaign
finance and how votes are counted first
past the post in order to make the third
party more reasonable more viable
how are we going to make those changes
uh so the forward party has two
major
endeavors uh in 2022. okay number one is
that and it turns out because the
political parties are made up
that we could actually get together and
change to an open primary rank choice
voting at the state level yes in 24
states around the country if just enough
of us got together and for people who
think like oh this will never happen it
happened last year in one state alaska
2020 changed from party primaries to
open primaries and ranked choice voting
and you immediately saw the result when
senator lisa murkowski of alaska voted
to impeach donald trump the only
republican senator to do so whose upper
reelection in 2022
her approval rating among alaskan
republicans is now six percent so it is
genuinely politically suicidal for a
republican to go against trump but she
can skip the party primary it doesn't
exist anymore you have an open primary
so she can take her case the entire
alaskan public
and then say look like i'm an
independent person bring me back so if
we make the same change that alaska made
in three four five states around the
country in 2022 imagine six eight ten
senators some of them republican who are
then free of the thrall of their party
free to do what they think is right
maybe they'll even support
uh protecting secretaries of state from
election interference you know like so
that this is something we can do if we
had enough americans get together and do
what they did in alaska so that's step
one which we don't have to wait for
anyone to do we can do it right now
there are none of us so that's what the
forward party is about trying to gather
that movement uh the second thing is we
can support candidates who are
uh fighting on principle
as democrats independents or republicans
and i'm just going to call out someone
who who i doubt people in your program
talk much about
there is a west virginia congressman
named david mckinley who co-sponsored a
cash relief bill that i lobbied for
and voted
yes on infrastructure he's one of the 13
republicans to do so he's now facing a
fight with a trumper um and who the heck
is going to help david mckinley like the
democrats would be like oh he's a
republican so screw it uh you know but
i'm going to suggest that a lot of
americans should be getting behind david
mckinley
and some other reasonable republicans
who are endangered species because
they're taking flack for doing the right
thing
um you meant so that's interesting so
you mentioned a republican
is there a prominent democrat right now
that people in my audience might know
that you think is particularly suited
and tailored for the the milieu
of the forward party as you describe it
i believe elizabeth warren came out as
pro-rank choice voting
when it was up on the ballot in
massachusetts last year so anyone who's
for rank choice voting i'm excited about
and there are a number of uh prominent
democrats and
uh democracy reformers who have taken
that stance i think corey might have
done so as well
i'm i'm really curious about the
coalition that you envisioned to some
degree you know when i told my audience
that you were going to be on the most
frequent question i got in different
iterations was
who exactly that currently considers
themselves to be on the right
does andrew yang imagine bringing into
the forward party and to kind of
make it a little more specific you know
we would imagine that there's lots of
progressive democrats more centrist
democrats even some folks who really
consider themselves centrist maybe in
the kind of line of even like a john
mccain who like the idea of some of the
reforms you're talking about and that
all kind of makes sense to me
when i think about people who believe
donald trump won the election
vaccines uh the covet vaccine magnetizes
you causes autism whatever the case may
be
etc right you know the package of ideas
that i'm talking about one are are those
people that would even conceivably say
this forward party idea that andrew yang
proposes in a coalition with the left
makes sense and number two are these
even people that you want as part of
your coalition
first let me say i want everyone as part
of the coalition you know if you can
vote we can disagree on a lot of things
uh it's all to the good if we agree on
the fact that this duopoly is uh not
working it's designed to turn us against
each other and sync us so that's one of
the principles of the ford party is that
look i can disagree with you on a lot of
stuff but if we can make common cause on
this then we can go back to disagreeing
when the democracy is actually set up to
succeed when they're you know
so let me i mean let me ask so even i
mean to make it really specific
if people on the right say the
republican party is too centrist i'm an
extreme white supremacist or something
like that but i think we need to get you
know we need single transferable vote or
whatever and campaign you you you still
welcome that because you're on the same
page on that one issue
yeah if they're going to help us
transition to a more effective democracy
um like you know i don't need to know
what their stance is on things that i
disagree with people have a sense of
where i'm coming from okay but right now
i believe that there is an existential
threat to the country um
as a result of the greatest design flaw
in the history of the world
and if if you will help us resolve that
design flaw then we can have a
discussion about anything else under the
sun at a time when the democracy
actually will stand the test of time
when we transition to a multi-party
system where you can't make any
autocratic or authoritarian decisions
you have to somehow get two or three
other parties on board okay all right
fair so on the question of is everyone
literally welcome the answer is yes
that's that's fine that's legitimate so
so you've that that's clear uh now in
terms of to whom
that currently typically votes for
republicans would this appeal
where are you on that
there are all sorts of folks who are
displeased with trump there's a person
online who said the other day it's like
look i voted for trump uh twice and i
don't even want him back
like there are voters out there uh who
are concerned about the country
uh and
i've i've been heartened by the fact
that i've gotten a lot of incoming
expressions of support from
military veterans
members of law enforcement or former law
enforcement who despair about the state
of the country they see where it's going
to and they say this is what i've been
waiting for
there's a an independent community
that right now is politically homeless
uh that they're very numerous there are
44 percent of americans consider
themselves independents
and i would say that
we're seeing a lot of them come in like
one of the things i'm going to suggest
first if you look at the appetite for a
third party it's higher among both
republicans and independents than
democrats so if you imagine who's going
to draw third party energy like if or
where it's going to come from it like by
the numbers it's likely to come from
those groups uh and imagining that every
republican or former republican or
independent uh is
excited about trump is just not right
you know but but saying that that group
is also
open to democrats is also not right i
have encountered so many americans who
just shut down when you have a d next
your name sure which i found unfortunate
but the thing i want to suggest to
people is that again all politics is
tribal at this point um and so what we
need to do is we need to have more
tribes emerge that we have a chance if
we stick to two tribes we're done
last thing i want to ask you about and
we're shifting gears a little bit but
because your background in technology
i'm very curious as to your insights
particularly as someone who who used
social media really effectively in the
democratic primary run that you made
all the talk now about the so-called
regulation of social media
one interesting um artifact of this has
been
the rapidity with which those who have
for a long time claimed businesses
should be able to do whatever they want
as long as it's not illegal are now
demanding
that social media companies be forced to
allow messages that violate their terms
of service to be up that's a hypocrisy
we could talk about but i don't want to
focus on that necessarily today what i'm
curious about from your perspective is
what should be the regulatory
infrastructure as to the social networks
particularly from this point of view of
political bias that don jr
whoever else are regularly tweeting
about and sort of saying we are the
victims here what what would you like to
see
i think our government needs to
modernize its approach to social media
and technology in general right now it's
behind the curve it's laughable or
embarrassing
this is also an outgrowth of our
geritocracy david i mean that the
reality is that our congressional
leaders are in their 70s or 80s if it is
biden versus trump in 24 which it looks
like it's going in that direction their
combined age will be 158 yeah so then
asking our government to understand
what's going on in social media is at
least right now a bridge too far and
like that has to change
if i were in charge
i would be getting into the guts of
these social media companies
setting what jonathan hype suggested as
like a filter where you end up being
able to just like ignore people who are
customarily aggressive obnoxious i mean
you can watch it if you want or get
those messages if you want but you
actually set up a way to reward people
who tend to be more balanced and normal
in their conversation okay because right
now the the energy in social media
rewards the more
aggressive or sensationalistic you're
self-accepted again you just like keep
it uh keep it even killed and yet
everyone loves you well you should see
the emails i get but so it sounds like
you're not saying you would be in favor
of the government going to youtube and
saying you've got to leave up
anti-vaccine content
well there are certain things that you'd
have to say are in the public good
uh that
you know and there's disinformation and
there's this information that can be uh
destructive in a way that you know like
if you are
a functioning society you do not want to
say like every idea is the same
including ideas that by the way in this
case could lead people to lose their
lives
so so in other words
you want to make it easier to control
one's experience on these platforms but
not take the approach that some on the
right are saying which is
these com these platforms should be
forced to allow content that violates
their terms of service again as long as
it's not illegal on the basis of
discrimination on
on race or sex or this type of thing
well i'm going to echo what some of the
social media ceos themselves say which
is like why are we in position to make
this decision
and the reason they're making that
decision is because the government is
absent
one of the social media ceo said look we
should get together
tech
government media
non-profits and set rules the road so
it's not just us doing the content
moderation decision then you yelling at
us about it because wherever they draw
the line they're going to get yelled at
you know i happen to think the
conservatives are off base in terms of
saying like oh you know you're sludging
conservative content it's like
conservative content actually performs
great on a lot of these platforms
and if there's anything we should be
concerned about it's the deteriorating
mental health of our young people
teenage girls in particular so if you're
a conservative like get mad about that
in my mind
right like yeah
depressed like isn't that a bigger issue
than the fact that you know anyway and i
guess then the question would become if
facebook knew that was going on and was
hiding it for a period of time are they
really good faith players to be involved
in figuring out the regulation which
which is sort of a second order question
well they can be at the table but we
should stop pretending that companies
are going to do anything other than
what's going to maximize their financial
returns which is exactly what you'd
expect them to do so
like so if you have that expectation and
then you go in and say hey guess what
we're going to do things that are going
to make your financial returns lower uh
and tough luck you know and and so one
thing i suggested as like a random thing
it's like maybe instagram should turn
off for teenagers between midnight and 7
a.m like you know maybe just looking at
pictures of your high school classmates
is something we don't want you to do in
the middle of the night you know like
you know
like
just like a random thought um and and so
you you can see that kind of like would
facebook be excited about that of course
not they'd be like oh we make money then
we make money all the time
uh the book is forward notes on the
future of our democracy i really
appreciate uh reading the book and uh
we've been speaking with the book's
author andrew yang always great having
you on and i really appreciate your time
thank you david great to be back